wahrscheinlich grübelt ihr wie ich
gerade an euren an bauplänen und ich
weiß dass es gar nicht so einfach ist
dabei alles zu beachten was man beachten
sollte also fruchtfolge mischkultur
gestartete aussaat und so weiter aber es
ist gleichzeitig auch eine total schöne
zeit im jahr wenn die saatgut kataloge
ins haus flattern und man sich
zurücklehnen kann sich zeit nehmen kann
ein bisschen träumen überlegen wie der
garten aussehen soll was man da
vielleicht anders machen möchte als
letztes jahr
und deswegen kommt hier wie da ein anbau
planungs video so dass ihr schritt für
schritt euren an bauplan mit mir
zusammen erstellen könnt denn ich weiß
dass einen das ganz schön überfordern
kann dass das ganz schön kompliziert ist
aber das muss es eigentlich gar nicht
sein und deswegen macht einfach mit geht
die schritte mit mir zusammen durch und
am ende haben wir alle diesen anbau plan
vorliegen und können raus gehen und
loslegen deswegen erstelle ich mir immer
eine liste mit allen gewesen wie so ein
kleiner wunschzettel eigentlich mit
allem was ich im nächsten jahr anbauen
möchte und wenn du gerade noch ganz am
anfang steht deiner garten karriere und
noch gar nicht so viele erfahrungen hast
dann schau dass du eher gemüseanbaus die
nicht so schwierig sind weil es gibt
schon so ein paar prinzessin wir gegen
diese welt wo man sich nicht unbedingt
darauf einlassen muss wenn man noch gar
keine erfahrung hat weil es manchmal
sehr frustrierend sein kann wenn es dann
eben nicht klappt also eher an die
einfachen gemüse halten da kann ich dir
gerne auch noch mal welche einblenden
die anderen kannst du dir dann für
später aufheben aber ich habe zum
beispiel meinen garten mit tagebuch eine
liste die auch jedes jahr ein bisschen
wächst weil es natürlich immer mal
wieder neue sachen gibt die spannend
sind und die ich ausprobieren will aber
im grunde habe ich hier eine liste mit
allen gemüsen die wir jedes jahr wieder
neu einbauen und das ist sehr praktisch
in der anbauplanung damit anzufangen so
dass man auf jeden fall keinen
kandidaten vergisst sonst kriege ich
ärger von meinen jungs wenn das nicht
auf dem tisch landet und so sieht meine
liste zum beispiel aus und dann können
wir weiter machen und zwar würde ich
euch im nächsten schritt einfach mal
dazu einladen einen fertigen
gartenplanung runterzuladen verlinkt ich
euch auch hier unter dem video und gerne
nochmal da in der info karte also ladet
euch den herunter dass das komplett
kostenlos weil anhand dessen kann nicht
an wunderbar erklären wie fruchtfolge
und mischkultur funktioniert und
gestaffelte aus st
dass du diesen anbau planen übernehmen
kann der schon steht und auf deine
bedürfnisse anpassen kann ist und auf
deinen garten übertragen kannst also lag
ihr denen die alle runter und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder wenn du den
geöffnet hast also dass ein pdf das
kannst du einfach am laptop öffnen oder
auch ausdrucken und die aufhängung da
ein kribbeln das ist natürlich noch viel
praktischer aber es geht auch
wunderbaren computer oder handy ende
werden gartenland vorliegen hast dann
können wir über die fruchtfolge sprechen
das ist insofern wichtig als dass
krankheiten und schädlinge die einen das
gern erleben ja ziemlich vermiesen
können oft auf einzelne gemüse
spezialisiert sind die sind ihre
lieblings gemüse und andere lassen sie
einfach außen vor und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass man nicht jedes jahr auf
ein und demselben wird immer wieder das
gleiche gemüse anbaut sondern da rotiert
und je nachdem in welcher
pflanzenfamilie ein gemüse isst und wie
hartnäckig die schädlinge und
krankheiten sind müssen dann mehr oder
weniger jahre vergehen bis das gleiche
gemüse wieder auf ein und demselben bild
angebaut werden sollte weil der anbau
plan so ausgelegt ist dass jedes jahr
jedes beet um einen platz weiter rückt
das heißt mit 1 rückt dann auf dem platz
wo jetzt b 2 und b 2 rückt einen platz
weiter so dass dieser anbau plan jahr
für jahr steht also der ist dann schon
fertige könnt den jahr für jahr wieder
verwenden müsst euch nächstes jahr nicht
nur mal hinsetzen und grübeln oder nur
leichte anpassungen machen venedig ein
bisschen vier rote beete gewesen dieses
jahr wollen wir lieber von dem und dem
gemüse statt dessen mehr haben
da kann man noch leichte anpassungen
machen aber im prinzip rotiert das jedes
jahr durch sodass ihr automatisch eine
supergute fruchtfolge einhalten
schau dir mal den pflanzplan an ich habe
jetzt den mai offen einfach weil da
schon viel gemüse im beet steht so dass
sich thema erklären kann wie das hier
bei dem anbau planen nämlich übrigens
auch bei mir draußen in meinem garten
umsätze wie das da funktioniert also da
habe ich zb festgelegt dass in weg 1 die
kohle wechsel und die zwiebel gewächse
wachsen weil kohl und lauch eine tolle
mischkultur sind
beide und einem schutznetz angebaut
werden sollten um noch mehr schädlinge
und krankheiten außen vor zu halten
die sind wirklich sehr sehr empfindlich
und deswegen sollten vor allem die kohl
gewechselt nur alle fünf bis sechs jahre
ungefähr auf ein und demselben bild
angebaut werden damit man da eben zb die
kohlen eine ganz schlimme krankheit
nicht in seinem garten hat weil dann
kann man im zweifel überhaupt keine
kohle anbau und lieber dafür sorgen dass
die pflanzen auf eine natürliche art und
weise die krankheiten und schädlinge
aushungern indem du einfach eine lange
pause eigen hältst und da habe ich jetzt
b1 quasi mit den familien kohlgemüse
wohl so cool gewächse und im lauf der ja
zu den zwiebelgewächse gehört blockiert
so dass wenn wir überlegen sollte man
nur alle sechs jahre im garten anbauen
nur eins von sechs beten mit kohl
bepflanzt werden sollte das ist voll
gemein weil es gibt so viele leckere
kohlgemüse aber ich versuche das in
meinem garten so gut es geht irgendwie
umzusetzen und das sehr einfach indem
man sich die beete einteilt in die
pflanzen familien geht einzig auch ein
stark zähler also sowohl auch als auch
pool sind stark wäre der knollensellerie
ist da auch noch mit dabei das ist
doldenblütler deswegen habe ich
festgelegt dass in bild 1 die kohl
gewächse wachsen und in keinem anderen
lauf und knollensellerie sind viele
gewächse und doldenblütler und die
werden auch noch in anderen bieten
vorkommen aber wird mit weitem abstand
weil die nur eine anbau pause von
ungefähr drei jahren brauchen so dass
wir auch noch ein weiteres boot mit
zwiebel sechsten und doldenblütler
bepflanzen können aber eben kein
weiteres boot mit kohl gemäss ich weiß
dass das team nicht kompliziert ist ich
blende euch hier auch nochmal eine liste
ein
mit den anbau abständen für die
einzelnen pflanzen familien so dass ihr
da selber einstellen könnt welche gemüse
die jetzt auf meiner liste stehen
gehören denn zu welchen pflanzen
familien und welche anbau abstellen muss
ich da einheiten und ich weiß dass man
da ganz schön puzzle muss aber mir hilft
es total wenn ich sozusagen die beete
label so dass ich sage okay geht eines
in chur gewächse die entwickler und
gehwege wächst und in b 2 habe ich dann
kürbisgewächse da seht ihr die gurke und
ich habe
nachtschattengewächse also ich hab da
die paprika die gurke und die zucchini
manche sagen über aber gurken und
zucchini soll man nicht auf einem beet
anbauen weil die nicht so gut für
mischkultur partner sind darüber
sprechen wir auch deswegen habe ich die
caprica dazwischen gibt's sonst so dass
sie möglichst weit auseinander sind und
ich trotzdem die fruchtfolge einhalten
kann also oft widerspricht sich das so
ein bisschen
und dann muss man eben schauen wie man
es trotzdem möglich macht dass alle
pflanzen eben ihren bedürfnissen
entsprechend in dem garten wachsen
können und das ist kompliziert aber es
macht auch spaß sich da mal hinzusetzen
und zu puzzeln und wenn ihr den pflanzen
auf eure bedürfnisse anpassen wollte da
sind alle fruchtfolgen und alle
mischkultur partner schon perfekt im
festgelegt also das ist schon eine
ziemlich cool denn ihr könnt alle gemüse
die hier in dem plan vorkommen wenn ihr
die nicht anbauen wollte einfach gegen
andere vertreter aus der gleichen
pflanzen familie austauschen und es
funktioniert trotzdem wunderbar er soll
den plan könnt ihr total gut an ihre
bedürfnisse anpassen oder einfach eins
zu eins so bei euch im garten umsetzen
sodass ihr euch diese gedanken gar nicht
erst machen müsst aber ich möchte dass
ihr fall steht damit ihr auch selber
einen eigenen pflanzplan erstellen könnt
also wir haben in die 2 die
kürbisgewächse und die
nachtschattengewächse und im b3 haben
wir dann also korbblütler das ist der
salat und im gänse fuß gewechselt wie
rote beete und mangold und die könnt ihr
einfach untereinander gegeneinander
austauschen dann haben wir auch beet
vier eben wieder zwiebelgewächse und
doldenblütler weil dann genug jahre
verstrichen sind nachdem die da
gewachsen sind biss der knollensellerie
der auch ein deutscher ist und der auch
der ja auch ein zwiebelgewächse ist
wieder auf diesem bild landen weil die
eben nur eine dreijährige anbau pause
haben auch bild 5 haben wir dann die
kartoffel
die hat dann genug abstand zu anderen
nachtschattengewächsen wie zum beispiel
der paprika auf b2 und b6 haben wir
leguminosen die wollen auch gerne weiter
an baupause deswegen haben die auch nur
ein bild bekommen das sind dann
zuckererbsen in dem fall und fußspuren
so dass die auch wieder nur alle sechs
jahre auf ein und demselben weg angebaut
werden können also das ist jetzt ein
plan für sechs bete ich hoffe dass eure
köpfe jetzt nicht schon komplett
brauchen sind aber
im prinzip könnte einfach diesen plan
übernehmen und einfach nur die gemüse
anpassen die ihr da jetzt vielleicht
vermisst oder die ihr da nicht lecker
findet und so werden wenn ihr zb 12
bitte habt dann nehmt ihr einfach diesen
plan verdoppelt den und passt in der
zweiten hälfte noch ein paar mehr gemüse
an so dass ihr mehr vielfalt in eurem
garten habt und das ist überhaupt kein
problem also das ist wirklich die
einfachste form einen pflanzplan zu
erstellen wenn man schon so eine fertige
und funktionierende vorlage schritt 7
sind die mischkultur partner die wir
festlegen wollen
und die sind in dem fall jetzt alle
schon beachtet so dass jedes gemüse gut
für mischkultur partner hat man muss
manchmal ein bisschen ein paar abstriche
machen zum beispiel b6 wachsen erbsen
neben boden das ist nicht so eine tolle
mission kultur aber eben ein kompromiss
die nicht gerne eingehen um die
fruchtfolge aufzulockern und wie sie
fliesenleger minuten krankheiten aus
meinem garten fernzuhalten mit denen ich
mich wirklich nicht herum ärgern möchte
aber zum beispiel enden ja die reihe nun
nebeneinander so dass nicht zwei reihen
parallel zueinander verlaufen so dass
die meisten pflanzen trotzdem genug
abstand zu den ärzten oder zu denen
bohnen haben und davon nicht großartig
geärgert werden aber achtet auf jeden
fall darauf dass ihr nur die gemüse
miteinander verkuppelt die auch gerne
zusammen auf einem weg wachsen dazu habe
ich auch schon mal ein video gemacht das
könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen genauso
wie ein video zur fruchtfolge ich
verlinke euch die weide gerne und in der
video beschreibung so dass ihr da noch
tiefer einsteigen könnt wenn ihr jetzt
über eurem an bauplan grübelt und am
ende genau die perfekt mischkultur
partner zusammengestellt die sich am
besten unterstützen die meisten
schädlinge und krankheiten fernhalten es
gibt ja ganz viele gründe warum
mischkultur sinnvoll ist und gerade in
den biogarten kann man damit so vielen
schädlingen und krankheiten vorbeugen
und vermeiden dass man eben die chemie
keule auspacken muss so dass ich das
wirklich jedem wärmstens ans herz legen
möchte in dem plan sind die mischkultur
partner jetzt schon so gut es geht
beachtet und denkt daran wenn ihre
pflanzplan erstellt dass man immer den
einen oder anderen kompromiss eingehen
muss so wie ich jetzt zum beispiel mit
den erbsen und bohnen die ich auf ein
gepackt habe wisse dass das nicht die
beste mischkultur ist aber dass es für
die fruchtfolge eben total sinnvoll ist
manchmal muss man eben ein paar
abstriche machen und dann ist das so
aber solange ihr euch im großen und
ganzen an die an bauplan regeln halten
macht ihr schon ganz ganz viel richtig
um euren garten auf natürliche art und
weise gesund zu halten dann ist es als
nächstes total sinnvoll wenn ihr auch
noch schaut wann ihr welches gemüse
anbaut also es ist nicht so klug wenn
man den garten einfach nur einmal im
frühjahr gepflanzt und beseelt und dann
im sommer eine riesengroße ernte
schwämme hat sondern es ist viel
schlauer wenn man regelmäßig kleinere
mengen gemüsebeet und pflanzt so dass
man eine gestaffelte ernte hat und da
eine schlaue satz planung hat so nennt
man das also einsatz ist quasi ein außer
zeitpunkt für ein gemüse
dass sich aber wiederholen kann über das
ja zum beispiel mache ich das so bei den
mühren dass ich da jeden monat einmal
möhren in meinem garten aussehen so dass
ich das ganze jahr über frische möhren
aus meinem garten ernten kann weil
ansonsten und das war in meinen ersten
garten ja absolut der fall hat man zwar
im frühling den ganzen garten gestellt
und überall wächst und blüht ist aber
sobald es dann juli wird wird man von
einer erntemenge erschlagen dass man
überhaupt keine lust mehr hat auf das
ganze genießt und dann im september ist
es auch schon wieder vorbei und man kann
wieder in den laden gehen und sich die
gemüse kaufen mit denen man zwei wochen
vorher noch jeden nachbarn ansporn für
lästig hat das irgendwie loszuwerden und
die einen schon nur um zu den ohren raus
gekommen sind dass es viel schlauer
regelmäßig kleinere mengen gemüse
anzubauen und gestaffelt auszusehen und
zu pflanzen und das ist natürlich auch
eine große planungs- frage so dass das
nicht passiert sondern dass man laufend
immer wieder frisches gemüse in
moderaten mengen ihren kann und weil das
ein sehr komplexes thema ist filme ich
euch dazu auch noch ein video so dass
wir das noch mal zusammen planen also
gerne den kanal abonnieren und die
glocke drücken wenn ihr es noch nicht
gemacht
damit ihr bescheid bekommt wenn die
nächsten planungsbüros erscheinen da
kommen auf jeden fall noch ein paar auf
euch zu dieses frühjahr dann schaut euch
auf jeden fall ne zwischenzeit noch mal
das video zur mischkultur an das
verlinkt ich euch da drüben
denn da zeige ich euch auf welche
mischkultur partnerschaften wie am
meisten setzen in unserem garten und
welche am wirkungsvollsten funktionieren